[MUSIC PLAYING]
PAUL RASHIDI: Hello, everyone.
Thanks for joining.
My name's Paul Rashidi.
I'm joined by Adam Rogal,
and we're part
of the DFP API team.
We're excited to host another
Hangout, so today we'll be
talking with Maanto about their
DFP API integration.
Maanto has robust solutions for
campaign analysis as well
as ad verification that
dramatically reduce workflow
for publishers that I think
you'll find quite interesting.
So without further ado, I'll
pass it over to Tom Denecke,
founder of Maanto, to show
us what Maanto does
and how they integrate.
TOM DENECKE: Thanks, Paul.
We are very glad to take part
in this Hangout here.
And I'm also very happy to have
Christoph here on my side.
He's our software architect
and knows all technical
details about our products.
And yeah, I guess in the next
30 minutes, we'll be most of
it online demo of
all our tools.
And we start with some facts
about our company.
We are a very specialized
software provider for a
segment of online marketing.
Our clients are sales houses,
publishers, and media agencies.
We are based here in Cologne,
Germany, and we have software
services, like AdShooter and
AdChecker, that we will show
in some minutes, business
intelligence solutions,
application development, and
also IT consulting services.
We have currently three
solutions based on the DFP
API, AdChecker and AdShooter,
already mentioned, and also
campaign reporting tools.
Here we put together delivery
data from the ad server and
also master data turned to XML
data from the older system,
for example, research
data like visibility
and view time trackings.
And all that is put together in
the application database.
And based on that, we have
analytical tools, dashboards,
alerting, and stuff like that.
So each user has his own access
and view on his KPIs.
Today, we will focus on
AdShooter and AdChecker.
And now we switch to the
workflow slide here.
So Christoph will tell you
about how the steps are.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, so we
have the workflow here.
And basically, we have two
technical parts, which is our
AdShooter application.
And on the other side,
we have the DFP API.
And the first thing we need
to do to get our AdShooter
running is to have daily
campaign imports.
So basically, we fetch the
campaign data, line item data,
of all campaigns of our
customers, fetch them to our
AdShooter application so that we
know which ads are actually
running and which ads we need
to take screenshots of.
So when we have this data, the
next step is to, of course,
make the screenshots.
For this, we've built our own
custom tool that allows us to
save up to 70% at a time that we
would usually require if we
have to do this manually.
So basically, what we do, we
have a list of all the running
campaigns, all the running ads
that we can go through from
top to bottom.
And it automatically fills in
details, like where to perform
these screenshots and which
URLs we need to use.
We have a preview of the
creatives, so we know which
creative is meant.
And once we've done this, once
we have our screenshots, the
next step is to inform the
sales house that their
screenshots are ready so they
can select the screenshots
they want to send out and to
approve these screenshots.
And once they've selected the
shots they want to use, and
they've approved them, the next
step is just to send a
mail with a download link to
the actual advertiser or
agency so they can download
these screenshots, either as a
zip package or as a PowerPoint
package.
So I'll switch back over
to Tom so he can
show you the demo.
TOM DENECKE: Thanks,
Christoph.
Now we will shortly have a
look at the application.
So here we are on the stat where
we have generated the
screenshots.
They are uploaded
to our server.
And then this mail, Christoph
mentioned, there is a deep
link included, so we click on
it, and then we are directed
here to this screenshot job.
And here we see an
example campaign.
It consists of three different
creatives.
It's a skyscraper, a medium
rectangle, and a super banner.
So what we can do here, we can,
for example, click on
that, and then we see the full
size here of the screenshot.
We can change here formats,
kind of cropping
feature we have here.
We can save it or
just go back.
And then we can select
those that we want
to send to our clients.
So we can say we only want to
send, for example, two of
those three.
So we would uncheck this here.
And we can also have a
look at the results.
We have the screenshot as a
JPEG file but also in a
PowerPoint file included.
So we check this button here,
open this PowerPoint example.
And yeah, we have first
title slide with
the corporate layout.
Here is the name of
the advertiser and
the campaign name.
And each following slide
contains the screenshot with
the description text here in
the header and also some
describing information here in
the comment, the creative and
ad IDs and the URL where the
screenshot was taken.
And we can close that
again here.
And the last step is to send
out those screenshots.
And this mail can be generated
here also in our application.
So we have here this
Mail button.
And then there is some
pre-configured information,
like recipient, subject.
You can type in some additional
information.
And then we just press here
Approve, and the screenshot
mail is generated
from our server.
And we see here how it
would look like.
We can have also a corporate
layout with some text and say,
hello, here's a new screenshot,
and here's those
three download links for the
image package, the PowerPoint,
and also both of that, again,
as in a zip file here.
So that was basically what you
can do with AdShooter.
So to sum that up--
MALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE].
TOM DENECKE: Sorry, yeah, the
AdShooter is really a
comprehensive solution for this
whole screenshot process.
We have some API features
here integrated.
We have the job list, which is
the result of our data import
process, where we use the API.
Also finding the creative is
based on this preview feature
of the API.
And then we have taken
the screenshots.
We format them, distribute
it, and also archiving.
So the benefit is this process
efficiency, we save a lot of
time, and you can offer
screenshots for all your
clients because it's so easy.
ADAM ROGAL: It's an
impressive tool.
So just diving a little bit into
the API there, maybe we
could discuss what calls to
the API you're making.
I know that you have two
parts there, which is
the campaign import.
And then it also looks like
you might be using the
line-item creative service,
the getPreview web call.
Maybe you guys can talk a little
bit about how you're
using both API calls.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, OK.
Well actually, we wanted to talk
about this later on, but
we can do it now.
So basically, as you mentioned,
we use pretty much
all the sales-side services,
I think it was--
sales-side services?
No, it's the other one?
Whatever.
We have the campaign
service for
fetching all active campaigns.
We use the line-item service of
course, to fetch the line
items of all these campaigns.
We use the creative service to
fetch the actual creatives.
And once we have these, we have
the line-item creative
associations, of course, to
match up the line items with
the corresponding creatives.
And then the line-item creative
association service
also allows us to get
the preview URL.
And then we also have the
inventory service that allows
us to know in which placements
the ads are supposed to be
shown so we know where to
take the screenshots.
So we're basically using the
API almost as a whole.
ADAM ROGAL: Great.
Thanks.
MALE SPEAKER: OK, so we'll
continue, then,
with the next product.
I'll switch back to Tom.
TOM DENECKE: OK, thanks.
So AdChecker is the product
that we offer as
software as a service.
Here's more about quality
management.
And what we have here is a tool
which checks if all those
technical parameters, like size,
performance, download
time, is OK.
So it's kind of a monitoring
system of all active creatives
and special features
for redirect ads.
Because here, the sales house
or the publisher, he doesn't
know what is going on when the
creative has changed so that
it's a special point here that
we track the whole campaign
delivery process here.
And we have email alerts if
there's a problem with that,
and we store all the checks
and kind of the history.
So the benefit is early
detection of possible
problems, and you're enabled
for proactive handling.
Christoph will now explain also
the AdChecker workflow.
MALE SPEAKER: OK, so basically,
it's very similar
to the AdShooter workflow.
We also, again, have
our AdChecker
application this time.
This also connects
to the DFP API to
import the active orders.
Pretty much the same as the
AdShooter application, we
check which ads are running,
so with that, we know which
ads we have to check.
So what happens is we perform
these continuous checks,
usually on a 24-hour schedule,
but we can change this
schedule if the customer
needs it.
And what we do is we open
these creatives that are
currently running, check their
file sizes, check especially
if they have changed in redirect
creative cases.
And if there's a problem with
any part of the creative, then
we can send out an email with
the problem summary to the
sales house so that they, in
turn, can analyze what's
happening and especially,
maybe, perform some
troubleshooting with the agency
or advertiser that may
be hosting the redirect
creative, in case there are
some issues there.
So onto the online demo.
I'll switch back to
Tom for this.
TOM DENECKE: Thanks.
OK, what we see here is our web
application with all the
results of our checks
that we performed.
And we got here some kind
of traffic light system.
So this is the list
of all active
creative for this publisher.
And for each [INAUDIBLE], we
have a column which indicates
if there's a problem.
So here, it's formats, file
size, download time, Flash
version, Flash frame rate, and
the download domain where it
comes from.
And if it's red, it indicates
here is a problem.
Yellow is a warning.
And if it's nothing to
be seen here, it's
green, so it's fine.
What is interesting here, we can
select those checks, and
we can filter all
that are red.
So we see here very quick
where are the problems.
We can do this here for each
check or for all those.
And another one, which is
another filter that is really
nice, this here, first
OK, and now red.
That means initially
that creative was
fine when it started.
But later on, it was changed,
and now it has a problem.
And there are those cases that
are hard to detect without
such tool support.
So let's get one step
deeper and have a
look in such a creative.
We have here a very
nice example.
It's a Batman creative.
And here we got the details
from this check history.
We see some details from
which order it came.
Here are the results
of the check.
So we see this creative
was 143 kilobytes big.
And our check condition is
lower than 50 is green,
between 50 and 60 is yellow,
and bigger than 60 is red.
So this one was red.
And also, here was a
little problem with
the download speed.
Flash version and so
on, this was OK.
So we see here in which
order it was used.
And when we come down here, we
have this check history.
So this one started here
on the 22nd of May.
It's an old example, and it
was checked four times.
And you see here, every time it
was red was the file size.
And one time, it has a problem
with download time.
And we can click on that here.
And it looks similar to the
other page, but here, we have
more details and see the result
of the specific check.
So if the creative would have
been changed, we would see
here another creative--
here, it's the same one--
and some more details
about the source
URL, stuff like that.
And for Flash creatives, we
also have here integrated
decompiler, so we can dig very
deep in details, like those
action scripts.
You'll see how it
was implemented.
And so it's very detailed
information.
Also, we have here the whole ad
request chain, so it leads
to the ad delivery.
And we see where were cookies
used and all that, so you get
a whole overview about
all requests.
And yeah, you can spend a lot
of time investigating the
problems here.
We've got other features, like
dashboards, Excel export, and
other things.
But I guess for a short
overview, that is enough at
this point here.
So yeah, any questions
for that?
PAUL RASHIDI: So I just wanted
to quickly ask, the comparison
you're doing, or the timeline,
basically, you're taking of
the creatives, are you using the
API to be able to detect
when the creatives
are changing?
Or are you picking that up
in your daily checks?
TOM DENECKE: I'm on?
OK.
When we check the creative,
we generate a hash key--
MD5 hash key.
And so when we compare it to the
last check, we know it has
changed or not.
So that is our mechanism
for that.
PAUL RASHIDI: OK.
But are you doing it on the ad
serving side, like you're
checking it from that end, or
are you using the API--
the PQL LastModifiedDateTime?
TOM DENECKE: No, we
don't use the API.
We use the result.
We pull the creative again,
and then we compare it
physically.
PAUL RASHIDI: OK, great.
ADAM ROGAL: Since a lot of other
developers do something
very similar, I was wondering if
maybe they might be looking
at this demo and then sort of
asking themselves how they can
do something similar.
It seems like what you'll be
doing is a lot of times, these
are third-party creatives, and
you're downloading the
creative that might be within
the asset that's within the
source code of it.
Or if it's a redirect URL,
you're following the URL down
the path to get the
actual asset.
Is that mostly the case here,
where you basically handle it
on different type
of creatives--
you handle it differently?
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, and the
thing is, with redirect
creatives, the problem
is it doesn't
change in the ad server.
So that's why we always have to
follow all these requests,
down to the actual creative,
to see if it has changed.
If it's a physical creative,
of course, we could
check in the API.
But in our case, it's just a
scheduled task that repeatedly
tries to get the
actual creative
that's being delivered.
So we have the creative code
from the API, and we just
basically paste this creative
code in a blank HTML page and
then analyze which requests
are being made.
ADAM ROGAL: And that's a good
point to make to our other
developers out there, is that
while LastModifiedDateTime in
the PQL query will get you
creatives that have been
modified, if we're hosting the
asset ourselves for redirect
creatives, yeah, the asset
might have changed.
So if you're dealing with a lot
of redirect creatives or
third-party creatives, where the
asset's hosted somewhere
else, that's a good point, too,
that you might need to
check that yourself.
TOM DENECKE: Correct.
PAUL RASHIDI: Great.
So I think next, you guys were
going to speak about your API
integration in a little bit
more detail, I believe.
MALE SPEAKER: Exactly.
We wanted to give a small
technical overview of what
we're doing, especially what
we're doing with the API.
Since we've already pretty much
said that we're working
with everything, I
think we can step
through this quite quickly.
Let me just share the
screen again.
OK, we have, basically, the two
parts of the API for our
transactional data for the
company service that I
mentioned-- the order service,
line-item service, inventory
service, and creative service.
So from the companies, of
course, we fetch the actual
advertiser, the person that
wants to advertise.
From the order service, we
get the active campaigns.
From the line-item service,
we get the line
items of the orders.
From the creatives,
we get all the
creatives that are running.
And then we associate them
through the line-item creative
associations.
And from the inventory service,
me fetch where these
creatives are supposed to be
shown or the line items.
And what we have is we have our
import tool, especially in
this case, the DFP6 importer
that connects to the API to
fetch all this master data so
that we can generate our job
lists so we know where to
perform the screenshots or
which ads we need to check
with the AdChecker.
And then there's also the
second part, the report
service that we use in some of
our other products where we
fetch the reporting data for
various campaigns and then use
this data to display dashboards
about which
campaigns we're running
how well.
And some of the highlights--
as you can imagine, we're not
using only the DFP API.
We've seen very many others.
And one of the highlights of
the DFP API that we really
love is the
LastModifiedDateTime, because
this allows us to perform
incremental updates.
So our importers, for some ad
servers, they run only once at
night, because they take quite
some time to finish.
And the DFP6 importer can
basically run once an hour, or
even more often, because with
the LastModifiedDateTime, we
can, one, filter by this so that
we can just take the last
entry we have in our tables--
the maximum
LastModifiedDateTime--
and query everything that's
higher than this.
And also, what we can do is we
can order it by this column.
So this basically allows us that
even if an import might
crash, we still have a
consistent state in our
database so that we always can
just say, what's our maximum
value of the
LastModifiedDateTime?
Continue on from there.
And that's something that we
have pretty much only seen in
the DFP API.
All the others have some
revision or other abilities
that go in this direction, but
none of them really compare to
this, because you can't continue
where you left off.
And that makes the DFP API
very practical for us.
And also, of course, the basis
for this is the PQL language,
which allows us to filter by
this column and to order by
this column and also fetch the
relevant data from all the
other services that we use.
So basically, we have
to say we were very
happy with the API.
PAUL RASHIDI: Great.
ADAM ROGAL: Well, thanks
very much.
One question I had for
you guys was--
we discussed earlier how
LastModifiedDateTime was not
as useful for creative
service.
Are you mostly using that for
the order service and
line-item service?
MALE SPEAKER: We are also using
it for the creative
service, because what we're
doing there is not checking
has the creative been modified
or anything.
But what we are doing is we are
fetching pretty much all
creatives so that if a creative
has changed, then we
get this change.
If it hasn't changed, we
don't need to fetch it.
ADAM ROGAL: Great.
MALE SPEAKER: But this also
means-- so it doesn't
necessarily have
to be modified.
The LastModifiedDateTime is also
when it's created, so we
are sure to get all
new creatives.
We have all the data we need,
all the current data.
ADAM ROGAL: Great point.
One other thing that I wanted to
bring up to some developers
who might be watching this is
that starting in v. 2012.11,
we're going to be supporting
unsupported creatives now.
So as the API evolves, and as
the product evolves, new
creatives get introduced.
In the past, a lot of these
would get filtered out.
It seems like in a tool like
AdChecker or the screenshot
tool, you'd want to have every
creative in your system.
So it seems like that would be
a good move for you guys is
the next step is to incorporate
the unsupported creatives.
TOM DENECKE: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: Exactly.
ADAM ROGAL: And just for people
who aren't familiar,
those extend the base
creative types.
So you still have the preview
URL where you can go
and fetch the asset.
You still have the size.
You still have the name,
and you also have the
LastModifiedDateTime.
So even if it's not fully
supported in API yet, you can
still check to see if
it's been modified.
TOM DENECKE: Mm hm.
Yep.
MALE SPEAKER: Exactly.
That's our next step.
ADAM ROGAL: Great.
PAUL RASHIDI: Christoph, did
you want to talk about
upgrades and any of the changes
you made for your
system in order to support
some of the upgrades
that are going on?
MALE SPEAKER: There wasn't
actually much that we needed
to change, because the upgrades
went pretty fluent.
What we did encounter was
exactly this point about the
missing creative types that came
after the version of the
API that we were using, which
might lead to exceptions when
fetching the creatives.
But with the new API, this has
also been removed, and all
other upgrades have been
pretty much fluent.
It was all some features that
were nice to have, especially,
I think, in the creative set
service, if I'm not mistaken.
I think we used the creative set
service for some reporting
applications, too.
We didn't have the
LastModifiedDateTime on the
creative sets, and this has been
also introduced in the
latest version.
So that's something
that's pretty
much an ongoing upgrade.
PAUL RASHIDI: Great.
ADAM ROGAL: And I just want
to point out, if you're a
developer and you're listening
to this, and you're basically
asking yourself, I have
feature requests, too.
How do I get these feature
requests known?
The forum is the best
place to go.
So if you go to the
DFP API forum,
please let us know there.
Paul and I are there every day
looking at feature requests.
The unsupported creatives, what
came out of the forum was
a big request from people there
wanting to get all their
creatives, even if they're not
fully supported, as well as
failing a little bit more
gracefully when you fetch down
a creative that might
not be supported.
Filtering might be a little
bit better than having
exceptions saying you
need to upgrade the
version of the API.
But it's a back-and-forth
process, and the API is
evolving every version.
And we really rely on our
developers to let us know what
they'd like to see in the API.
The reason that we get a lot
of compliments is the
developers themselves.
They're the ones who suggest
all these great
features, like PQL.
That came out of a big developer
question of, hey,
how can I just select out things
that are named "my
creative?"
One thing I wanted to ask
you guys is, I noticed
you're using C#.
Are you using one of our
client libraries?
MALE SPEAKER: Indeed, we are.
Yes.
We actually wish the C# library
would be more in time
with the actual release of the
APIs, because we sometimes
have to wait about a week.
But on the other hand, a week
is not long to wait for
something like this.
ADAM ROGAL: It's good that you
guys are eager to start using
new features of the API.
We appreciate that.
But that is definitely
some feedback that I
can give back to--
So Paul and myself belong to
the same team, that we both
support the API.
And we write the SDKs and
the client libraries.
And if that's feedback that you
have, that other people
have similar feedback, we love
to hear that kind of feedback.
That means that you guys are
excited to use the new
features, and it's something--
it means that it's easy for
you guys to integrate new
versions, which we love, as
well, because that means more
developers are on
newer versions.
And we can iterate a lot faster
on these new features
for you guys.
So I'll definitely bring that
back to the developer.
Like you said, we try and aim
for about a week after the
version release to release the
client library release, but we
can try and speed that up a
little bit if that means a lot
to you guys.
PAUL RASHIDI: Great.
ADAM ROGAL: Paul, do you
want to say something?
PAUL RASHIDI: Go ahead.
I was just going to say we're
getting close to time.
But [INAUDIBLE].
ADAM ROGAL: So one last question
is, it seems like--
I remember working with Maanto
for a long time now, and you
guys are, I would say, experts
in the API now.
For a lot of our beginners out
there, maybe folks who are
trying to write their first DFP
API application, do you
have any advice that you want to
give them in some of those
first baby steps they
might want to take?
MALE SPEAKER: Basically, I'd say
first, get acclimated to
the nomenclature, because if you
first enter the field and
you hear something like
an order line item--
what the hell is a line item?
So first of all, you need to
introduce yourself to this.
Then, when you've handled the
nomenclature, get take the
programming language of your
choice, get the API, and just
try some stuff out.
Play around with the API.
That's the best way to learn.
ADAM ROGAL: And what do you
think the best way to play
around with the API is?
I've heard examples are good.
The Playground is good.
What would you suggest?
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, just try
fetching information.
Try putting some information
into the system if you need
this use case.
In our case, we pretty much
rely only on fetching of
information.
So just see what your
use case needs--
what you need from the service,
and try getting the
information you need.
Usually, you'll find it's
pretty easy to get the
information that you wanted,
once you know where to look.
But everything is usually
well sorted.
ADAM ROGAL: So basically, you
can't learn to build a house
unless you pick up a hammer.
MALE SPEAKER: Right.
ADAM ROGAL: All right.
Thanks very much.
PAUL RASHIDI: For newer
developers out there, I just
want to mention that the
developer website for
DoubleClick for Publishers does
have instructions in how
to create a test network.
So very easy to follow.
You can actually create one from
the API itself or use our
Playground to create one with
any Google account.
ADAM ROGAL: And that's just
dfp-playground.appspot.com.
So it's very easy to remember.
You go there, and you can create
a test network in a
couple steps.
PAUL RASHIDI: All right.
Gentlemen, thank you very much
for joining us today during
this Hangout.
Thank you, everyone on the
internet, for joining us or
watching this later.
We really appreciate everyone's
time, and we will
see you again for one
of these shortly.
TOM DENECKE: Thank
you very much.
PAUL RASHIDI: Thank you.
TOM DENECKE: Bye bye.
PAUL RASHIDI: Bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]